so erica your race is the congressional
the 30th district of california
um which is western los angeles i
believe uh
yes like the west valley the west san
fernando valley and you
did something i think everyone can
understand immediately that everyone
kind of aspires to in their lives but
very few people do you want teacher of
the year
my first year of teaching which is
incredible
for developing a science curriculum for
kids that that
helped them learn in new ways can you
talk about
how you decided to be an educator and
what your initial experiences were
because a lot of people
i'll just speak for myself but i think
this is pretty universal you know wendy
you can
like agree with this probably it's like
we all grew up with teachers
because we're around teachers and so a
lot of us at one point thought to
ourselves
maybe i want to be a teacher
you know i think that was a very natural
thought for a lot of kids uh
and so did you always know that you
wanted to be a teacher and then what was
your experience
like actually getting trained as an
educator and then showing up
in the public schools so no
i never wanted to be a teacher but um
but what ended up happening was um i
came across this woman
who was like an on-set tutor and while i
was in college i was like oh that seems
like a really cool gig to have
you know while i'm in college and then i
just ended up going through the
credential
process and i had to do observation
hours and in the classroom that i was
assigned to
we had fifth graders that could not even
read andrew
and it literally broke my heart because
i was in the third grade
and i still i was not fully literate and
so it took
that teacher i still remember her my
parents getting me everything that i
needed to make sure that i can
read and so it was like this instant
connection and then
it was in that moment where i decided to
devote my life to education
fast forward i got my credential
i got my first job and um
i was hired as a science teacher because
my master's degree is in curriculum and
instruction with an emphasis in science
and my principal at the time she was
like gave me
creative freedom she's like dream it up
and for
a first year teacher that can be like
kind of daunting like this crazy task
but i was like you know what how do i
learn
what have i learned through the whole
credential process and i
went to my mentor professor baca who's
no longer with us but she
is my mentor she's shaped how i teach
and i dreamed up something that was
hands-on field trip based
kid-led the constructive constructive
approach to learning
and it ended up getting the kids hyped
about science like
every lesson everything's like a dream
it is a dream
and every lesson every time we were
doing hands-on
experiments and it was so fun and then i
was nominated
to be teacher of the year my very first
year by the los angeles clippers
and then that just kind of catapulted my
career in education
and at the school that i'm at now is
really the model
in which i think education should go
where it's field trip teachers are paid
and compensated well
kids are at the the priority because i
think that's what education should be
where the kids are where we start with
and super attendance are kind of last
and and i think it's part of reason why
i
want to be it is reason why i want to be
on the education committee in congress
that's like my end goal
that would be so wonderful that's what
i'm working towards and
can i just plug that what's my signature
policy that i'm very proud of
is my kids have a voice to program and
so a
section of my campaign is literally
operated by young people
so they came they come up with events
they write policies they dream up things
and they
run a whole section of our campaign and
so basically
my goal is to cultivate the next
generation of leaders and i have to give
reverend wendy a real thank you because
not only has she helped
give advice to this program but she has
also participated
in different events that my my kids in
my district
have done and i think that's why i want
to be with her
because right like wendy like will work
with anyone that
has the best interest of young people
and so i just want to just let everyone
know
like she's for real about young people
too and i think that's what we're
missing in education is letting kids
feel empowered
and having a voice in the process
especially when they don't get to vote
these policies affect them but they
don't get to vote on them so it's our
responsibility
to make sure that they have a space and
room at the table
and so that's what i'm excited about so
i take it you were for my
proposal to lower the voting age to 16.
i have it on my platform
nice i have it on my platform it's the
same thing you can pay taxes might as
well
be able to know where it goes right and
one of my girls on my campaign
she wrote a whole presentation for me on
why it should be
16 and not 15. so kids really care about
this
so thank you for running on that so
you've worked in both public and private
schools and this is such like a
you know central issue for so many
communities like do you have any
thoughts
on uh what you've seen in different
environments
and what we can do to frankly teach our
kids uh
better yeah there is a difference
and i think what it is is with i think
it really comes down to accessibility
and resources
you know so at you know when you work in
a private school
you tend to have more resources to do
the hands-on
um to have creative freedom to go on
field trips
because it's you're not working through
a system um
public schools have different challenges
and benefits
right but i would say when i worked at a
public school
the kids were just absolutely astounded
they were just amazing like they they
wanted that
they wanted to um have these same
experiences and i think for me what i
had to do
was find ways to fund them and i think
that's that's what i want to fix like i
want to make sure teachers are paid more
and that we are making sure that
teachers have resources
because when teachers have resources we
know that they can flourish
like teachers should never have to pay
for a lesson
like i can't like when i was of course
like all of us are thinking to ourselves
teachers have to pay for lessons
it's wild it's absolutely wild and
you know i can't even begin to tell you
how much i invested in my own classroom
i'm happy to do it
but i mean our teachers though that's
not cool
yeah we shouldn't and so i really think
that we need to reprioritize funding
and make sure teachers are compensated
well and that teachers get stipends so
something that i'm proposing is that
teachers at the beginning of the year
get a thousand dollar stipend
so they can invest in their classroom
and tailor their curriculum to
the resources in which they need to to
innovate and create
and have those hands-on opportunities
and then i think it should be sustained
throughout the school year and obviously
there's some public a lot of public
um policy so i'm
saying that even if i'm in washington
i'm willing to work with our local
officials to make that stuff possible
that's a tremendous idea and one of the
things that
i'm hearing in your proposals which i
agree with
is that we should be investing resources
as close to the kids as possible and and
what's closer than the teacher
you know there's a lot of money getting
spent on stuff that is not in that
classroom
and paying teachers more to me uh is one
of the first moves you make
where and if you look at the numbers uh
we're actually spending a good deal in
the united states to
uh educate our kids it's just not not
enough it's going to the teacher and the
fact that teachers have to do what
you've done
which is spend their own money that they
don't really have a lot of
excess in to to buy materials or lessons
for their kids
uh it's just wrong so uh like i i
couldn't agree with you more
so wendy on your side you you've done a
lot of things as i uh said before
you who've worked in communications in
capitol hill you've been a
communications professor
you worked with someone who's like a
major major forces
ben jealous who's the ceo of the naacp
who i i know you know like i i'm
friendly with ben i like i don't know
him well
we have a lot of people in common um and
you've been engaged
in uh criminal justice reform
uh in environmental issues
um and and during that time you've also
obviously uh become
uh a reverend and been ministering to
people's spiritual lives
i think we've recently seen a greater
intersection between
um faith and public service and maybe
i'm just thinking of it because of
reverend warnock's victory in atlanta
which i'm sure both of you are super
pumped about the same way
yes this is a city
that is ripe for someone who
is looking to come and be involved in a
culturally diverse active engaging
group of citizens who really care about
their future
you mentioned ben ben jealous was the
youngest
president in the history of the naacp
back in 2008
when i came on alongside ben who's a
dear friend now who's
actually now the president and ceo of
people for the american way
which is a non-profit here in dc so
working with ben and even working at the
headquarters in the naacp was an
eye-opening experience
i was with ben during the time that
trayvon martin um
was killed uh there was a big death
penalty case with troy davis for those
who might remember troy davis who was on
death row
um and a lot of advocacy work that went
into
attempting to save his life and so
as you mentioned i was in this sort of
social justice service people
uh space that give gave me
such a sense of wanting to do more and
and help because there's such a need
and it can almost feel overwhelming at
times you you think you're you know
you're putting out one fire here and
then
something raises up over there and so
having been sort of a person of faith
but not necessarily in ministry
i finally decided to explore that and
actually
when i was working on the hill you
mentioned that i did work on the hill
four season in a as
a communications capacity they had a
bible study there
that was led by the current senate
chaplain
uh barry black admiral barry black he's
the
chaplain of the senate he's the first
african-american to become the chaplain
of the senate
wonderful guy turned out to be a mentor
of mine actually wrote my recommendation
letter to go to seminary at howard
university
so howard for me uh transformed my life
both as an undergrad and then going back
on the master's degree level
and i knew from that point on that it
was my
calling to serve and to reconnect and to
inspire
and to motivate people to be what
they've been called to be
and to do what they've been called to do
and so the
any types of activities i've become
involved in i'm
inspired by them i don't do things for
clout or do you know so some people
would say
why congress like you know i you know i
kind of got that question one of the
things we haven't talked about
uh is that similar to erica we're both
running against
incumbents uh 30-year incumbents
and so you might imagine you have two of
us coming along with all of this yang
energy you know
and they're like oh yeah energy i like
the sound of them
you know and they're asking you know
where did they come from and what are
they attempting to do but for me
i believe in him i believe in stepping
into roles that you feel connected to
you know i know when you were running
people used to say why'd he start out at
president why didn't he start out you
know at
city council or something like that and
like you
the problems were so big you feel like
you need to be at the top
of the of the heap to make any kind of
indentation
into them and so for me also
understanding my gifts
i am an advocacy person i know how to
to visualize and to speak and to
represent if you need my voice
on the record about what is right and
what is just
and what needs to be done in this moment
for this particular group of people or
even for this individual group
that's me i'm your person and that's why
i'm running
[Music]
you